I've been sitting on the many Lewis cons
for a little while now because they
didn't really seem to be going anywhere
however the most recent Edition talks of
some potential support come in the
division's way they could really mix
things up
[Music]
Frederick Lewis screw up in the ocean
when old enough he joined the North
Carolina coast guard and over the course
of time worked his way up to the
prestigious search and rescue team after
getting married he and his wife would
move Inland where he would run a farm
due to the need for a little more
excitement in his life Lewis joined the
National Guard but when his marriage
eventually ended he wasted no time in
moving back to North Carolina and
rejoining the Coast Guard
unfortunately not long after returning
the green poison was released
when the Joint Task Force was
established his Coast Guard unit would
be sent to New York to help the jtf in
DC Lewis would be placed under Colonel
Antoine ridgeway's command and when
Ridge West stopped taking orders from
above and started taking matters into
his own hands Lewis was one of the
soldiers loyal to his cause who would
free him from the jtf prison then
becoming the true Sons
after ridgeway's death General Anderson
would take the reins Lewis would
continue with his loyalties towards the
true Sons
Anderson would eventually have Lewis
carry out an operation in DC they were
hunting for something and they have now
found it
Lewis and his men head to the Jefferson
Trade Center immediately
this is where the division catch up with
them except he is all alone the last
member of his team
Lewis and the division team up to take
down the Black Tusk who have taken hold
of the site but while in there they
learn of an individual called the
recruiter the Target that Lewis and
Anderson seem to have been hunting
once the Black Tusk threat had been
removed and the recruiter had vanished
Lewis and the division parted ways
not long after this operation we would
find out that many and Lewis have been
communicating
that was before you joined Ridgeway
I thought I knew you Fred you do know me
don't be like that you killed people
This Is War Manny we've all killed
people it's not the same you know that
whatever helps you sleep at night what
do you want Fred to help surrender into
custody and we've got a nice cell ready
with your name on it
I said I want to help being in jail
doesn't help you not having to wonder
anymore in front of my agents is going
to punch your clock that helps me access
helps you Manny and I've got access
Manny and Lewis worked alongside each
other in the jtf all the way up until
the day that Colonel Antoine Ridgeway
turned his back on the government after
losing faith in their ability to do what
was needed to make it through the
pandemic
the jtf around Ridgeway were faced with
a choice
to fall back to the other jtf units or
to join this new band calling themselves
the true Sons becoming an enemy of the
country
many fell back keeping to his oath while
Lewis sided with Ridgeway agreeing that
things needed to be done differently if
the country was going to survive
many and Lewis weren't just colleagues
they were friends so many took this
betrayal pretty hard
how could someone trusted so deeply
makes such a bad judgment call the jtf
is the combined forces of all the
remaining police officers firefighters
Army National Guardsmen and other civil
and military branches they are the good
guys what is he doing joining up with a
group that is essentially the enemy
working against them
but Lewis still feels that what he did
was justified however under Anderson
things have now changed
he wants to help put a stop to Anderson
and Natalia's plans
however many is going to need a little
more than just words to be convinced
that Lewis is suddenly now interested in
helping the right side
[Music]
no pretty sure that would blew my cover
for all I know you're doing recon for
Anderson and this is a trap that's why I
wanted to meet so I can stare into your
eyes and know you're telling the truth
something like that
where do you want to meet
many are still very skeptical but Lewis
assures him that if they meet face to
face he'll be able to help them
understand that he really just wants to
help
you actually came alone need to build
trust
have to actually keep your word right
you didn't come along did you no but for
good reason
the Intel I wanted to share with you is
Wally nice to meet you Manny apparently
a person is Intel now we've met we have
yeah DC protest crowd control back in
December oh [ __ ] that's right
oh how's your uncle dead how's your
sister Dad how's my dog fine
ransom's running around here somewhere
well that's something at least what
Intel do you have Wally we've been
maintaining a power plant in Fairview
yeah
a bunch of the engineers we want to
defect
Anderson is making Promises to the Black
Tusk we don't want any part of what he's
planning
Manny and Lewis meet up in person but
Lewis hasn't come alone he brings
someone called Wally who appears to be
an engineer at the Fairview power plant
and like Lewis she wants nothing to do
with what Anderson is planning
interestingly enough many knows her too
so she must have been a part of the jtf
as well
so I guess the big question here is what
is Anderson planning and how does this
involve the power plant
not much has been said on Wally just yet
but I get the feeling we'll be hearing
more about this character soon
there's more on our side now how many
more 100 maybe 120 there's too many Fred
Anderson is going to suspect something's
up he's too busy trying to impress
Natalya he doesn't know his ass from his
elbow I don't have an extra 100 beds
Fred we're not ready to move yet anyway
but get ready when we pull the trigger
you're gonna have a new Army at your
disposal that's what I'm afraid of what
are you afraid of that your Army's gonna
show up and my agent is going to shoot
first and ask questions later
we don't know who we can trust and if
Anderson gets wind of a mutiny before
you're ready that puts all of you in
danger you're too cautious and you're
too Reckless have faith
and get ready
lose proudly and excitedly announces
that he's managed to find over a hundred
true Sun soldiers who are willing to
follow him in joining up with many the
jtf and the division
but he wasn't expecting many to react in
the way that he did which is weird I
thought he knew many the most panicky
character in the division universe
however in this case many is probably
right to be concerned how can Lewis
really know and trust that many people
to know that they won't let this planned
abandonment get back to Anderson it
could be due to someone attempting to
bolster their rank within the true Sons
willing to work undercover and gather
Intel or someone could just slip up
regardless this is all moving very
quickly and many is the type to like a
very solid plan in place before acting
on anything at this stage he hasn't even
alerted the jtf in the division to what
he's been organizing with Lewis let
alone where he'll be able to house and
feed so many extra bodies
many is probably being a little over
cautious but Lewis is definitely being
Reckless
an army of 100 plus xjtf extrus Sons
will certainly come in useful as the
division agents haven't had any real
support for quite some time now but this
won't be enough to take down the Black
Tusk and the remaining true sons who
stayed loyal to Anderson so what is
their plan
will this force be tasked with taking
down Anderson in the final Manhunt and
whatever he's doing at Fairview power
plant
interesting stuff starting to come
through these many Lewis comms it'll be
pretty cool starting to work with some
of the true Sons I really hope this
leads to larger scale battles in the
future
I hate having to say this again but on
this channel I don't cover glitches
exploits and leaks so please be
thoughtful towards other members of the
community and me who don't wish to have
the story spoiled and would rather have
it play out as intended
otherwise I'm stoked with the turn these
cons are taking admittedly they started
off a little slow but I guess the scene
had to be set
summing up Lewis has reached out to his
old jtf buddy from back in the day many
in his offering to help stop Anderson
on top of this he has managed to
persuade a large number of other true
Sons to follow him and join the jtf and
Division in the upcoming fight
I'm pretty Keen to see how this plays
out but I'm also very interested in what
Anderson is planning and what part the
Fairview power plant will play in this
anyway that's enough for now thank you
very much for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one and don't forget
extremist malice extrema remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]